lo que siempre encuentro increíble de la
química es que es un campo entero de la
ciencia que los seres humanos hemos
desarrollado para entender realmente lo
que pasa en una escala casi inimaginable
mente pequeña en particular vamos a
estar pensando en la escala atómica e
incluso subatómica al estudiar esta
escala podemos empezar a entender el
universo en el que vivimos la escala en
la que vivimos e incluso vamos a ser
capaces de hacer predicciones sobre lo
que sucederá así como crear cosas que
son útiles para los seres humanos
entonces si vamos a trabajar con esta
pequeña escala que en un segundo
podremos apreciar qué tan pequeña es
entonces tenemos que tener algunas
unidades de medida en este vídeo nos
enfocaremos en la masa cómo medimos la
masa en una escala muy pequeña
bueno para medir la la comunidad química
ha usado algo que históricamente se le
conoce como unidad de masa atómica que
se denota como uma y más recientemente
una versión moderna de esta unidad es la
unidad de masa atómica unificada que se
denota solo con una y en lugar de una
ahora bien como se conecta la unidad de
masa atómica unificada con las unidades
de masa que ya conocemos en una escala
mayor como los gramos o kilogramos bueno
la unidad de masa atómica unificada se
define como 1.66 05 40 por 10 a la menos
27 kilogramos
entonces cuando vemos algo así tenemos
algunas reacciones nuestra primera
reacción la cual es muy apropiada es
decir wow 10 a la menos 27 es un valor
muy pequeño para apreciarlo tendremos
que escribir 0 punto y después 26 ceros
y después 16 60 540 es decir tenemos un
valor muy muy pequeño realmente
inimaginablemente pequeño sólo podemos
intentar abstraer algo así con cosas
como las matemáticas la otra cosa que
seguramente apreciamos es que esto se ve
como un numero peliagudo 1.660 540
porque lo definen de esa forma y la
respuesta a esta pregunta es que esta
definición hace que sea mucho más claro
pensar en la masa de un átomo o las
partes de un átomo como un protón o un
neutrón
la masa de un protón es aproximadamente
una unidad de masa atómica unificada la
masa de un neutrón es aproximadamente
una unidad de masa atómica unificada
de hecho la masa del protón es
ligeramente mayor que 1 es
aproximadamente 1.007 unidades de masa
atómica unificadas que es
aproximadamente 1 mientras que la masa
de un neutrón es un poco mayor que la
del protón es aproximadamente 1.008
unidades de masa atómica unificadas por
su parte la masa de un electrón es mucho
menor que estas dos de hecho es un 200
sabor de un protón o un neutrón entonces
puedes imaginar que en un átomo que está
hecho de protones electrones y
normalmente neutrones la masa va a ser
principalmente de los protones y
neutrones
justo en el núcleo así que si sabes el
número de protones y neutrones en el
núcleo vas a tener una estimación
bastante buena de su masa atómica y eso
mismo lo puedes ver en la tabla
periódica de los elementos que tenemos
aquí ya hemos estudiado con más detalle
en la tabla periódica en otros vídeos
pero podemos ver en ella un par de datos
interesantes sobre los elementos primero
cada letra representa la abreviatura de
un elemento dado por ejemplo la h
representa el hidrógeno el número de
arriba en la tabla periódica es el
número atómico esto nos dice la cantidad
de protones que tiene ese elemento de
hecho un elemento se define por el
número de protones así que cualquiera
átomo que tenga exactamente un protón en
su núcleo por definición será un
hidrógeno cualquier átomo que tenga 20
protones en su núcleo por definición
será un calcio cualquier átomo que tenga
36 protones en su núcleo por definición
será un crypton entonces cuál crees que
sea la masa de un átomo de hidrógeno
pausa el vídeo y piénsalo
bueno sabemos que todos los átomos de
hidrógeno por definición tienen un
protón pero resulta que hay varias
versiones diferentes del hidrógeno que
pueden tener un distinto número de
neutrones en realidad la mayoría de los
hidrógenos del universo tienen cero
neutrones aunque hay versiones que
tienen uno o dos neutrones pero
aproximadamente el 99 punto 98% del
hidrógeno del universo tiene un protón y
cero neutrones y si es un hidrógeno
neutro tendrá un electrón y estas
versiones de un elemento dado tienen un
nombre elegante isótopos los diferentes
isótopos de un átomo tienen el mismo
número de protones porque hablamos del
mismo elemento pero distinto número de
neutrones
esta es la forma más común del hidrógeno
cuál quieres que sea su masa bueno
básicamente su masa será la suma de la
masa de un protón y un electrón y
aproximadamente será la masa de un
protón ya que la masa de un protón es
mucho más grande que la masa del
electrón así que esperamos que su masa
sea aproximadamente una unidad de masa
atómica unificada ahora si queremos
saber de manera precisa la masa de un
electrón y un protón y la sumamos vamos
a obtener algo muy cercano a 1.008 y
puedes verlo justo aquí en la tabla
periódica este número a pesar de ser muy
cercano a la masa de la versión del
hidrógeno que acabamos de escribir es de
hecho una masa promedio ponderada de las
varias versiones del hidrógeno es muy
cercana a esta versión porque ésta
representa la mayor parte del hidrógeno
que percibimos alrededor de nosotros si
por ejemplo tenemos dos versiones de un
elemento hipotético y vamos a decir que
un 80%
que veamos es la versión 1 y la versión
1 tiene una masa de no sé propongamos
cinco unidades de masa atómica
unificadas y lo restante un 20% del
elemento que vemos es la versión 2 que
vamos a suponer que tiene una masa
atómica de 6 unidades de masa atómica
unificadas entonces obtenemos una masa
promedio de 5 punto dos unidades de masa
atómica unificadas y justo así es como
se calculan estos valores no es sólo la
masa de un tipo de elemento es el
promedio de la masa ponderada de los
distintos isótopos entonces a este
número en la tabla periódica se le
conoce como la masa atómica promedio en
los libros de química antiguos y este es
el caso cuando aprendí química por
primera vez este valor solía tener el
nombre de peso atómico y siempre me he
quejado de esto porque estamos hablando
de masa
si no sabes la diferencia la conocerás
en algún momento pero realmente se está
hablando de masa atómica promedio ahora
vamos a ver un detalle que seguro no
será útil a veces escucharemos algo
llamado masa atómica relativa que se ve
en esta tabla periódica ya que observa
los valores no tienen escrito una
pequeña y al final es decir estos
valores no tienen unidades así que
estamos hablando de masa atómica
relativa que nos dice que en promedio
por ejemplo la masa de un átomo de
carbono es aproximadamente 12 veces la
masa atómica del átomo de hidrógeno y si
pusieran las unidades aquí entonces
realmente sería la masa atómica promedio
pero para nuestros propósitos en nuestro
estudio en la química podemos ver estos
números y decir ok si el oxígeno tiene
una masa atómica relativa de 16 su masa
atómica promedio será 16 unidades de
masa atómica unificadas y como veremos
en el futuro entender esta masa atómica
promedio no será muy muy muy útil